>>> AN INTERESTING NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN THE PROXY FIGHT.
THAT'S THE DAY BEFORE THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY ELECTION FOR
GOVERNOR IN THE STATE.
IT PITS THE CANDIDATE OF PENCE
AND THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT
AGAINST THE ONE ENDORSED BY
FORMER PRESIDENT, FORMER GEORGIA
SENATOR DAVID PURDUE.
MAGGIE, DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP FEELS?
>> HE'S NOT HAPPY ABOUT IT.
IT'S BEEN HEADING THIS WAY FOR A
WHILE THAT MIKE PENCE'S TOP
AIDE, MARK SHORT, WAS WITH BRYAN
KEMP.
PENCE HAS BEEN LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO SEPARATE OUT FROM TRUMP AND
HIGHLIGHT THAT HE DOES NOT
SUPPORT TRUMP'S FALSE CLAIMS
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
REMEMBER, IT WAS THOSE CLAIMS
THAT LEAD TO HANG MIKE PENCE
CHANTS.
I DON'T THINK TRUMP IS HAPPY
ABOUT THIS.
HOW HE CHOOSES TO VENT THAT OR
MAKE IT PUBLIC REMAINS TO BE
SEEN.
LOOK, MIKE PENCE IS COMING IN AT
A TIME WHEN IT'S CLEAR THAT
BRYAN KEMP IS IN A PRETTY GOOD
POSITION.
IT'S NOT AS IF PENCE IS GOING TO
PUT HIM OVER THE TOP.
PENCE IS MAKING A STATEMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP USED TO BE A
BIG FAN OF THE GOVERNOR KEMP.
DURING THE EARLY DAYS OF COVID I
REMEMBER HIM AT PRESS
CONFERENCES TALKING ABOUT HOW
GREAT THE GOVERNOR WAS AND HOW
HE HAVE HANDLING IT SO WELL.
WAS IT ONLY THAT KEMP WASN'T
TOUTING THE BIG LIE THAT TURNED
HIM AGAINST HIM?
>> HE'S BEEN UNHAPPY WITH KEMP
FOR A WHILE GOING BACK TO THE
CHOICE OF KELLY LEFFLER TO TAKE
THE OPEN SENATE SEAT IN GEORGIA
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
THAT WAS THE SOURCE OF THE RIFT
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM.
TRUMP CREDITED HIMSELF WITH
GETTING KEMP ELECTED AND WAS A
VERY CLOSE RACE IN 2018 IN
GEORGIA.
TRUMP ALWAYS CREDITS HIMSELF FOR
ANYBODY ELSE'S WIN BUT IN THAT
CASE TRUMP DID MAKE TRIPS TO THE
STATE.
THAT RIFT CAME LONG BEFORE WHAT
WE SAW.
I THINK HIS RAISE OF KEMP WAS TO
CONTRAST WITH OVER GOVERNORS.
>> THE DAVID PURDUE LOSES, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN FOR TRUMP IN
LONGER TERM?
>> I THINK IT'S HARD TO SEE A
LONG TERM END IN TERMS OF WHAT
THIS MEANS FOR TRUMP NOW.
I THINK TRUMP COULD HAVE A BAD
REST OF MAY WITH THE PRIMARIES
UPCOMING NEXT WEEK AND THE WEEK
AFTER.
IT STILL DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING
FOR HIM FOR 2024.
WHAT IT DOES MEAN IS HIS KING
MAKING ABILITIES ARE LIMITED.
IT DOES MEAN HE'S UNLEASHED
SOMETHING HE CAN'T REALLY
CONTAIN ANYMORE WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BECAUSE ALL OF
THESE PRIMARY FIELDS LOOK A LOT
LIKE PRO-TRUMP REPUBLICANS.
IN THE CASE OF THIS ENDORSEMENT,
KEMP, ON POLICY, MOST
REPUBLICANS IN THE STATE FEEL AS
IF HE'S PRETTY GOOD.
THERE WAS THIS ONE ISSUE WHICH
IS THE ELECTION AND A LOT OF
THESE VOTERS ARE NOT VOTING ON
THAT.
PURDUE HAS HAD A CANDIDACY WITH
REALLY NO MESSAGE.
IN GENERAL, FOR THE MOST PART,
HIS RACE WAS ALL ABOUT 2020 AND
THAT'S JUST NOT WHAT PRIMARY
VOTERS WANT TO VOTE ON.
>> IT'S ALSO NOT JUST PENCE.
MIKE POMPEO BROKE IN THE
PENNSYLVANIA SENATE RACE
ENDORSING SOMEONE ELSE INSTEAD
OF TRUMP ENDORSED CANDIDATE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
MIKE POMPEO WAS FRIENDS WITH THE
CANDIDATE HE BACKED.
IT PUT HIM AT ODDS WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I THINK THE QUESTION, ANDERSON,
IS DO WE KEEP SEEING PEOPLE
CREEPING AWAY FROM TRUMP AND
DOES THAT CREATE AN OPENING
WHERE PEOPLE FEEL AS IF THEY CAN
CHALLENGE HIM FOR 2024.
I THINK WE WILL KNOW MUCH MORE
AT THE END OF MAY.
>> AXIOS SAYS TRUMP IS LEADING
TOWARD ENDORSING DOUG MASTRIAON.
IS THAT A REFERENDUM ON THE BIG
LIE.
HE'S ALL IN ON THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT A
REFERENDUM BUT IT'S SHOWING
THERE'S SOME ENERGY FOR IT IN
CERTAIN PLACES.
I THINK THERE'S OTHER FACTORS IN
WORK IN THAT PRIMARY.
TRUMP IS LOOKING LESS ABOUT HIS
LIES ABOUT THE ELECTION IN THAT
CASE AS WHY HE WOULD SUPPORT
MASTRIANO.